hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
klartext mit sigmar gabriel und wolfgang
bosbach
hallo eine situation die ihnen
vielleicht gar nicht so fremd es man
gibt ein interview auf der straße es
laufen passanten vorbei und pöbeln
ordentlich ja da kann man schon mal die
fassung verlieren auch vor laufender
kamera
so erging es nun grünen politiker cem
özdemir und wir wollen uns im moment
einmal anschauen
die informationen die wir haben dass es
keinen politischen hintergrund hat ist
ja schon mal kein anlass zur entwarnung
im gegenteil das macht es schwieriger
denn bei den politischen hintergrund ist
klar wohin war mittels ich rede ja wir
sind hier in deutschland mit dem maul
halten danke zur verteidigung cem
özdemir hat sich inzwischen auf twitter
entschuldigt mit den worten fresse hätte
mir nicht rausrutschen dürfen bei ihnen
beiden fein mir spontan auch momente ein
in denen mit ihnen mal das temperament
durchgegangen ist herr gabriel da gab es
ein gewisses interview im zdf heute
journal
herr bosbach sie haben einmal
wutentbrannt eine sendung maischberger
verlassen
die frage an sie gab es einen moment in
ihrer politischen karriere in denen sie
wie auch ausgeflippt sind aber die
kamera nicht liefen und sie sich danach
gedacht haben ein glück dass jetzt
niemand mitgeschnitten hat herr gabriel
ganz still die augen aber bestimmt
solche situationen klar
sie können sich gar nicht mehr dran
erinnern herr bosbach wie sieht's ja
nicht immer ist alles druckreif und es
ist auch richtig wenn die kamera an ist
so wie jetzt in diesem moment dann
überlegt man sich jedes wort dreimal
denn wenn es gesendet worden ist kann
man es ja nicht mehr zurückholen
das hätte cem özdemir nicht passieren
dürfen aber es ist passiert und ich
finde es sympathisch dass sie sich dafür
sofort entschuldigt hat herr gabriel wie
groß ist denn der druck der auf ihm
lastet als politiker wo man ständig
unter beobachtung steht und wirkliches
gefühl hat man muss permanent sich im
politisch korrekt verhalten äußern in
jeder situation wie groß ist der druck
da ja der mediale druck ist schon groß
und der ist natürlich heute viel größer
ist der dass vor 30 jahren gewesen ist
wo es zwei drei sender gab keine
sozialen netzwerke aber was ist vor
allen dingen verändert hat ich weiß was
ich überhaupt campos passiert aber ich
habe das so erlebt dass den letzten
jahren die aggressivität öffentlich
total zugenommen hat und dafür einen
langen arbeitstag hinter sich hat denn
dann kommt an meiner quer und wirbelt
dazwischen mit ziemlich oben und wie zum
beispiel deutschland sei ein
polizeistaat oder eine polizei diktatur
kann man schon mal sagen jetzt zeige ich
den vogel oder wird ausfallen das ist
nicht schön hat er gemacht
entschuldige aber das kann schon mal
passieren und der sah die summe an
wahnsinn wie man so den tag über zu
hören bekommen wie schon erstaunlich
geworden wir sind damit auf jeden fall
bei unserem ersten großen thema
angekommen den ausschreitungen in
stuttgart knapp 500 randalierer
zerstörten und plünderten samstagnacht
geschäfte griffen polizisten an warfen
sie mit flaschen und steinen wir wollen
uns mal ein paar fotos anschauen
ja hier sieht man eben wie die
randalierer scheiben einschlugen
geschäfte plünderten sie ihre gewalt auf
den straßen brutalität vandalismus 24
menschen wurden vorläufig festgenommen
darunter auch minderjährige und man
fragt sich wie kann es sein dass in
einem doch so beschaulichen
gutbürgerlichen wohlhabenden örtchen wie
stuttgart solche ausschreitungen
passieren können habe das bach also der
hinweis auf die partyszene die es
übertrieben hat oder die außer kontrolle
geraten ist überzeugt mich ehrlich
gesagt nicht ich muss zugeben ich weiß
nicht wie in stuttgart partys gefeiert
werden aber jedenfalls im rheinland sind
sturmhauben eher selten dabei
das war ja ein ganz massiver
gewaltausbruch den wir dort haben den
kennen wir andere dings aus bitteren
erfahrungen der vergangenheit nehmen sie
mal ein ezb eröffnung g20-gipfel in
hamburg es war immer eine große
menschenmenge aus der heraus straftaten
gewalttaten begangen wurden sind
natürlich gibt es auch ganz gewiss die
kombination alkohol war im spiel bei
einigen dürften auch drogen im spiel
gewesen sein aber das in dieser form
hundertfach massive gewalt ausgeübt wird
das schlimmste ist ja diese dieser
gewaltausbruch mit gestreckten beinen
gegenüber den polizisten der gerade am
boden kniet dass das uns alle erschreckt
ist klar ich füge hinzu wir sind jetzt
in der phase 1 empörung
ich fürchte es wird nicht lange dauern
dann kommt die phase 2 relativierung und
dann hoffe ich das nicht so schnell die
phase 3 kommt nämlich übergang zur
tagesordnung her gab er auch an sie noch
mal die frage können sie sich das
erklären wie es zu solchen
gewaltausschreitungen kommen konnte
erinnern sie sich es gab es auch früher
ich habe miterlebt als
landtagsabgeordneter in niedersachsen
die chaostage in hannover oder das
eigentlich in der nacht zum ersten mai
oder silvester in berlin die bürger
solchen gedacht haben
wir können da mal randalieren und
prügeleien mit der polizei anfangen
das hat glaube ich ganz unterschiedliche
gründe ein teil ist ganz sicher dass bei
einem teil von jüngeren manchmal auch
älteren nicht mehr klar ist was es heißt
dass das gewaltmonopol band starten und
das ist eine frage von erziehung das ist
eine frage von der sichtbarkeit und der
fähigkeit polizeilicher präsenz übrigens
auch eine frage wie schnell werden
eigentlich täter hinterher abgeurteilt
wenn er es lange zeit vergeht zwischen
tat und urteil dann ist schon vieles
wieder vergessen
ich persönlich bin übrigen auch der
überzeugung dass sowas wie
körperverletzungsdelikte am anfang
fehler bestraft werden müssen wir haben
oftmals eine situation wo sich langsam
das strafmaß über die zeit dann erst
nach oben entwickelt da können leute den
eindruck haben durch schnelle schlimm
ist es ja nicht wenn ich sowas mache es
hat ganz viele gründe aber
offensichtlich auch die lust die blues
am randalieren und an der gewalt und das
ist keineswegs so dass das nur migranten
sind das sind es offensichtlich auch
gewesen wie man gelesen hat und gehört
hat aber eben auch scannen sie unter
deutschen jungen leuten jugendlichen
jungen erwachsenen aus den letzten
jahren auch lust den staat
herauszufordern und ich glaube dass man
da auch nur mit einer null toleranz
politik reagieren kann
herr bosbach die lust den staat
herauszufordern hat zugenommen auch die
gewalt gegen polizisten sanitäter und
notärzte
warum wir erleben das doch schon seit
jahren dass der respekt vor staatlichen
autoritäten nicht überall und
flächendeckend aber doch in weiten
teilen der bevölkerung abnimmt
wir haben es mit vermehrten angriffen zu
tun nicht nur auf polizistinnen und
polizisten auf sanitäter auf
rettungskräfte feuerwehr die bei ihren
rettungsbemühungen gestört wenn nicht
gar angegriffen werden
und wenn sich morgens ein polizist seine
uniform anzieht dann trägt er das
landeswappen
das bundeswappen und damit repräsentiert
er den start
und vielleicht sollte man hat darauf
hinweisen die polizei muss in erster
linie die schwachen schützen
die staaten können sich schon selber
schützen oder sie sind nicht so auf den
schutz der sicherheitsbehörden
angewiesen wie die schwachen und das ist
eine missachtung staatlicher autorität
der sinkt der respekt und gerade vor dem
hintergrund der debatten die wir in den
letzten tagen geführt haben da dürfen
sich einige nicht wundern sie haben es
ganz sicherlich nicht gewollt was da
passiert ist aber gerade unsere polizei
braucht loyalität braucht unterstützung
aus der bevölkerung aus der politik und
die politik sollte der polizei den
rücken stärken ihr nicht in den rücken
fallen es gibt keinen grund die polizei
unter generalverdacht zu stellen und die
polizei selbst hat ein überragendes
interesse daran dass es in ihren reihen
keine schwarzen schafe gibt stichwort
loyalität und unterstützung herr gabriel
sie haben auf twitter eine aktion
vorgeschlagen und zwar einen button eine
art solidaritäts button zu tragen mit
der aufschrift wir sind polizei wo ist
denn ihr warten heute nachmittag gemacht
ist kann ich leider nicht selber basteln
die letzte button maschine die ich hatte
ich so ein langer weg aber ich hab es
auch ein bisschen es gibt es zu als
provokation gemeint bei allen möglichen
dingen wenn gewalt ins entsteht dann
gibt es schnell menschlich sagen das
wollen wir nicht dagegen setzen maria
der spruch wir sind kommt ja daher ist
es gott sei dank nicht vergleichbar mit
den morden an john f
ich will das überhaupt nicht vergleichen
aber es ist doch erstaunlich dass wenn
sowas polizisten passiert oder anders
gesagt rettungssanitätern
feuerwehrleuten dass da irgendwie das
nur zu einem politischen problem gemacht
wird und nicht die gesellschaft
insgesamt darauf mal reagiert ich finde
das ehrlich gesagt unglaublich die
polizei feuerwehr rettungskräfte setzten
sie ihr eigenes leben und gesundheit ein
um andere zu schützen und wenn jemand
verdient hat dass man sich an ihrer
seite stellt dann doch diejenigen die so
was tun und
ich meine ich habe gebe ich zu ich war
einigermaßen konsterniert wie sozusagen
die auseinandersetzung zwischen polizei
und schwarzen in den usa am beispiel von
lloyd george dazu geführt dass wir hier
eine rassismus debatte bei der deutschen
polizei hatten
natürlich wird es auch in der polizei
rassismus geben so wie es das in der
ganzen deutschen gesellschaft gibt sich
polizei ist ein spiegel will aber
ehrlich gesagt das ist eine so
demokratisch kontrollierte organisation
das ist eine große erfolgsgeschichte die
demokratische polizei in deutschland
nach 1945 sie im generalverdacht zu
nehmen oder zu vergleichen weil bei uns
müssen sie drei jahre lang eine
ausbildung machen dann gehen sie an die
bereitschaftspolizei in den usa können
712 nach sechs monaten oder auch sechs
wochen polizist werden
ich finde das geht so nicht man muss
auch ein bisschen aufpassen dass man
nicht einfach jede sau durchs dorf
treibt sondern sich an die seite
derjenigen stehe die diesen staat oder
präsentieren übrigens das gilt nicht nur
für polizisten rettungskräfte und
sanitäter feuerwehrleute
fragen sie mal was lehrerinnen und
lehrer so im alltag erleben oder leute
die auch der auf der arbeitsagentur
arbeiten und ich glaube dass wir die
diesen staat garantieren dann auch in
besonderer weise in schutz nehmen müssen
also so weit wird diesen button
produziert haben werden wir den auf
jeden fall auch ansehen weil er
ausliefern und dann sehen wir ihnen ja
vielleicht das nächste mal angesteckt in
der nächsten sendung die polizei war
auch inhalt einer sehr sehr umstrittenen
kolumne in der taz die inzwischen dem
presserat juristen im innenministerium
und selbst die kanzlerin beschäftigt
konkret heißt es in der kolumne
wenn die polizei abgeschafft wird der
kapitalismus jedoch nicht in welche
branchen kann man ex-cop es dann
überhaupt noch rein lassen um am ende
mit der idee zu kommen
zitat spontan fällt mir nur eine
geeignete option ein die mülldeponie
nicht als menschen mit schlüsseln zu
häusern sondern auf der halde wo sie
wirklich nur von abfall umgeben sind
unter ihresgleichen fühlen sie sich
bestimmt auch selbst am wohlsten
also polizisten sollen auf der
mülldeponie entsorgt werden
ziemlich geschmacklos keine frage aber
ist der text denn gedeckt durch
meinungs- und pressefreiheit was würden
sie sagen darf ein journalist sowas
veröffentlichen herr bosbach
letztendlich werden darüber die
strafverfolgungsbehörden entscheiden
denn es ist ja bereits strafanzeige
erstattet worden ich glaube durch die
deutsche polizeigewerkschaft
ich ahne wie dieses ermittlungsverfahren
ausgeht ich selber halte diesen text für
unsäglich
jetzt fehlt nur noch dass diejenigen die
diesen text für unsäglich halten in die
ecke gestellt werden sie würden jetzt
die pressefreiheit in deutschland in
gefahr bringen
wenn es ohne konsequenzen möglich wenn
nicht mehr möglich wäre gruppen in
dieser form zu beleidigen
ich habe in 68 jahren selten einen
schlimmeren text gelesen und jetzt jetzt
kommt der berühmte satz von kurt
tucholsky satire darf alles dass bayern
nur spaß es ist ja nur ein literarischer
scherz gemacht worden ist noch nicht
ernst gemeint wer in dieser form
polizistinnen und polizisten sozusagen
auf der müllhalde entsorgen will warum
es bei den ganzen artikel lesen
das ist ja nur der höhepunkt einer ganz
traurigen argumentation
es ist ja geradezu unmenschlich wieder
mit den beamtinnen und beamten
umgegangen wird dass das überhaupt in
der taz gehalten sich ja da seit
jahrzehnten für moralisch besonders hoch
stehen veröffentlicht werden konnte das
überrascht mich schon ich weiß auch dass
es debatten gibt in der redaktion
ob man diesen text überhaupt hätte
veröffentlichen dürfen oder nicht
ich gehe mal davon aus dass das
ermittlungsverfahren im sande verläuft
aber wer diesen text für unsäglich hält
und kritisiert er bringt nicht die
meinungsfreiheit in gefahr
herr gabriel wie sehen sie das
so schön stilvoll gesagt dass man so wie
man das wort sagen würde
das kann doch nicht wahr sein dass eine
chefredaktion auch so etwas durchgehen
lässt
bei allem verständnis für die debatte um
meinungsfreiheit wie journalisten die
das geschrieben hat wie kann das deshalb
schreiben weil sie in einem rechtsstaat
lädt der von der polizei die sie
bestimmen
beschützt er geht es offensichtlich so
gut und ich war dann anders kann ich mir
das nicht erklären wie kann man dieses
lang und die guten verhältnisse in denen
wir hier leben gibt milliarden menschen
auf der welt wie würden sich diese art
demokratischer polizei wünschen wie wir
in deutschland haben
wie kann man die derartig beleidigen und
dazu fällt mir ehrlich gesagt nichts
höflich ist mir ein ich wolfgang gerne
zugehört habe das mit großem hier
bewusst sei neben verpackter seine
kritik ich wie gesagt finde ich ganz bei
trost ich habe die das geschrieben hat
vielleicht wenn ich jetzt eine anzeige
weil ich mich ja ich über sie äußere
aber was einer fällt mir ein
seehofer ja auch angekündigt juristisch
dagegen vorgehen zu wollen wird wohl
aktuell von der kanzlerin etwas
ausgebremst denn die beiden stünden in
vertraulichen gesprächen teilte
regierungssprecher seibert dazu mit darf
ein innenminister eine journalistin den
anzeigen herr bosbach ja das ist nicht
verboten
und ich kann das sogar verstehen dass
der bundesinnenminister sich schützend
als dienstherr bevor seine polizei
stellt vor die die bundespolizei auch
für die mitarbeiter im bundeskriminalamt
es politisch klug ist ist eine andere
frage
zum einen macht er damit die autorin
unnötiger populär und zum anderen eine
ich wie gerade schon gesagt wie das
ermittlungsverfahren ausgeht ich glaube
nicht dass es zu einer strafrechtlichen
sanktionen kommen wird und wenn ja wird
das rauf gehen bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht immer wieder
wird dieser text zitiert und publiziert
werden
diesen gefallen sollten wir die autorin
unter das nicht tun
herr gabriel hätten sehr ähnlich
gehandelt
während sie aktuell innenminister kennen
können sie es verstehen
ja ich kann es gut verstehen auch wenn
ich dazu neige dass politik sich mit
journalisten nicht über gericht
auseinandersetzen sollten ja ich kann
gut verstehen ich meine hat eine pflicht
und fürsorgepflicht für seine
polizeibeamten polizei haben und
deswegen hat er sich vor sie gestellt
das wieder damit ja dokumentieren ich
glaube auch ich wollte meine post gehabt
dass das ausgeht die sonneberger
schießen aber ich kann schon verstehen
dass der bundesinnenminister sagte sie
weiter auch in dieser woche beschäftigt
uns weiterhin die fleischindustrie bei
tönnies sind inzwischen mehr als 1500
mitarbeiter positiv auf corona getestet
worden
noch immer befinden sich die knapp 6000
mitarbeiter der fleischfabrik in
gütersloh in quarantäne und nicht nur
dass der gesamte landkreis plus der
nachbar kreis warendorf also gütersloh
und warendorf wer denn jetzt zurück
geworfen um wochen und zwar wurden
wieder regeln eingeführt wie wir sie
hatten im märz zu zeiten des lockdown
bewohner dürfen beispielsweise nur noch
mit mitgliedern des eigenen haushalts
auf die straße gehen und fitnessstudios
kinos und bars wurden geschlossen
arbeitsminister heil hat nun
vorgeschlagen das tennis für die schäden
durch den corona ausbruch haftbar
gemacht werden sollte gute idee und die
frage an wie wenn ja wofür sollte tan
jetzt denn haften für die
wirtschaftlichen schäden in der region
die nun entstehen also beispielsweise
einnahmeausfälle von besitzern oder von
künstlern für mehrkosten durch den
einsatz von polizisten und bundeswehr
soldaten die jetzt aktuell auch
eingesetzt werden um quarantäne
durchzusetzen oder für die massenhaften
corona test also wofür genau sollte
turniers zahlen herr bosbach ja das
müssten sie diejenigen fragen die sagen
tourismus für den entstandenen schaden
haften ich kann nur sagen gleiches recht
für alle da wir ja zunächst mal prüfen
zu prüfen ob gesetzliche vorschriften
verletzt worden sind rechtsverordnungen
erlassen was auch immer oder ob sich
tönnies an recht und gesetz gehalten
man kann jetzt bei der firma thöni es
nicht andere maßstäbe anlegen als bei
anderen unternehmen
wenn die gesetzlichen voraussetzungen
für schadenersatz vorliegen dann wird
die zuständige behörde daraus die
notwendigen konsequenzen ziehen
aber wir hatten auch in anderen
unternehmen ausbrüche infektionen die
ausgestrahlt haben und deswegen wird man
das sehr sehr sorgfältig juristisch
prüfen müssen
ich habe allerdings die firma thöni es
so verstanden dass man auch ohne
staatlichen druck zumindest erhebliche
kosten tragen will unabhängig von der
frage ob man sie tragen muss oder nicht
das gilt jedenfalls für die massentest
sie jetzt vorgenommen werden müssen
aber wenn die haftungs begründung
voraussetzungen vorliegen und wenn der
kraft und kausalität hergestellt werden
kann zwischen rechtsverstößen und einem
konkreten schaden der eingetreten ist
dann stellt sich natürlich auch die
frage der haftpflicht also hier die
frage des schadenersatzes kann jetzt
soll haften für schäden würden sie ihren
kollegen arbeitsminister zustimmen dazu
müsste man bei trainiert das hat
wolfgang richtig dargestellt zwei dinge
klären erstens gab es vorsatz ich
vermute eher nein oder ganz gewissen ein
zweites grob fahrlässig war auch da
vermute ich eher nein also man wird
untersuchen müssen auch er wie wolfgang
was war das gesagt hat gegen recht und
gesetz verstoßen hat wenn er nicht getan
hat dann kann man ihn nicht anders
behandeln als beispielsweise den
veranstalter der karnevalsveranstaltung
damals in nordrhein westfalen als das
los ging oder andere ausdruck serie bei
denen sich das coroner virus entwickelt
ich glaube ich dass wird darüber werden
die zuständigen behörden das tun wir
werden prüfen ob das unternehmen
turniers gegen recht und gesetz
verstoßen haben wenn das nicht der fall
ist gibt es keinen grund schlechter zu
behandeln als ein mitarbeiter der firma
erzählten zb der süddeutschen zeitung
aus ihrem arbeitsalltag unter
nahmen 200 stunden arbeit im monat 1500
schweine pro stunde zitat schlachten im
akkord unterkünfte in denen sich fordert
pandemie drei bis sieben personen ein
zimmer teilen und sich vor den
sammelbildern schlangen bildeten
arbeitsplatz putzen galt nicht als
arbeitszeit immerhin gab es in den
vergangenen jahren in den unterkünften
anders als früher
so wurde berichtet kein schimmel mehr
keine kakerlaken und keine offenen
elektroleitungen mehr verdient habe der
rumäne wir sagt sechs bis sieben euro
pro stunde
letzte woche haben sie gesagt sie werden
kein böses wort über clemens tönnies
verlieren noch mal nachgefragt auch wenn
da jetzt subunternehmen
zwischengeschaltet sind was sagt es dann
über einen unternehmer aus der menschen
unter diesen bedingungen für sich
arbeiten lässt herr bosbach
sv mörsch bauer ich kenne das
unternehmen nicht ich habe es nie
besucht ich habe auch vorige woche
gesagt über den unternehmen mehr und
über das unternehmen tun dies kann ich
keine auskunft erteilen wenn ich mir
persönlich noch nie einen eindruck
machen konnte über die
arbeitsbedingungen über die
wohnverhältnisse deren mitarbeiter das
zitat bezog sich auf meine persönlichen
begegnungen mit herrn tönnies weit
außerhalb des betriebes bei geselligen
anlässen wo ich ihn kennen und schätzen
gelernt habe ich darf darum bitten dass
man fein auseinanderzuhalten
das wäre dann weit entfernt vom
gesetzlichen mindestlohn der übrigens
auch an diejenigen zu zahlen ist die
hier in deutschland arbeiten da kommt es
nämlich auf die staatsangehörigkeit
überhaupt nicht an wir haben eine eu
entsenderichtlinie
vielleicht gibt es auch tarifverträge
und das aber ja gerade an anderer stelle
darüber gesprochen
die hygienebedingungen arbeitsschutz
bedingungen dass die eingehalten werden
müssen
keine frage wir haben schon in der
letzten sendung gesagt nichts absolut
nichts spricht dagegen für strengere
anforderungen zu sorgen am arbeitsplatz
selber und im hinblick auf die
wohnverhältnisse dann aber
hätte in der gesamten branche und nicht
nur für einen einzelnen betrieb und wir
haben ausbrüche also infektions
ausbrüche auch dort wo nicht viele
menschen auf engstem raum zusammenleben
und wir haben ein großes
infektionsgeschehen dort wo die
stammbelegschaft betroffen ist wir haben
das in kanada in den usa wir haben das
in brasilien weil offensichtlich die
arbeitsumgebung in den schlachthöfen
besonders geeignet ist um sich zu
infizieren niedrige temperaturen um die
4 grad herum ist eine ideale temperatur
für die verbreitung des virus
dort ist es relativ laute rufen sich
viel zu und sie atmen schwer
so herr bosbach hat jetzt den großen
bogen gespannt bis nach brasilien
allerdings die frage nicht beantwortet
vielleicht möchten sie noch mal herr
gabriel was sagt das über einen
unternehmer aus wenn mitarbeiter unter
diesen bedingungen arbeiten
ob die aussage stimmt ich habe in meiner
zeit als wirtschaftsminister mit der
fleischbrühe über die arbeitsbedingungen
verhandelt insbesondere jennis war
damals bereich erstens einen branchen
mindestlohn einzuführen der ist dann
später durch den gesetzten mindestlohn
überholt worden wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere waren
der durchschnittslohn bei den werks
arbeitnehmern lag über 12 euro in der
stunde
zweites tennis hat damals mit ungefähr
zwei drittel der anderen in der fleisch
rolle tätigen zugestimmt alle werks
vertrags arbeitnehmer auch die aus
bulgarien rumänien oder polen nach
deutschem arbeitsrecht zu beschäftigen
also in deutschland sozial zu haben
das sind die dinge die wir damals
verabredet haben ich habe jetzt schon
ein fahrer gesagt man müsste mal
überprüfen das ist ja nur ein paar jahre
her
ob das dabei geblieben ist und übrigens
wir haben damals mit ihm auch vor dass
er in die wohnbedingungen investieren
soll
wenn ich das richtig erinnere ist damals
auch nur in rheda wiedenbrück
an benannt worden dafür und wir haben
natürlich auch mit den betriebsräten
geredet also die bedingungen da sind
jedenfalls in meiner erinnerung nicht so
gewesen dass das alles nicht sehr massen
unterkünfte ja da waren manchmal sechs
leute in einer wohl noch nicht in einem
zimmer einer wohnung
dennoch sagen warum weil die leute die
da sind das geld nach hause schicken
wollen und nicht in deutschland für eine
bestimmte wohnqualität ausgeben wollen
und es gibt grenzen dessen was ein
arbeitgeber seinen arbeitnehmern oder
den werks vertrags aber niemand
vorschreiben darf wo sie zu wohnen haben
was allerdings geht ist dass der staat
in nordrhein westfalen wie wohnen und
der fünfte auch überprüft für bucklige
bedingungen sind da wird da wenn da
sozusagen gegen hygiene standards
verstoßen das alles geht aber dass die
bedingungen im schnitt so sein wie sie
das eben von diesem einen arbeitnehmer
zitiert haben das jedenfalls war zu
meiner zeit als ich den betrieb damals
gesucht habe nicht so insofern müsste
man jetzt mal überprüfen ist das
schlechter geworden
stimmt das was er sagt und woran liegt
das letzte bemerkung dazu ich bin da
muss aufpassen dass man zwei dinge nicht
vermischen
das eine ist und daran arbeitet der
bundesarbeitsminister ja die
verbesserung der arbeits und
entlohnungsbedingungen das ist auch
nötig in der ganzen branche das zweite
aber ist unter welchen bedingungen kann
man dort eigentlich arbeiten und das
ständig des virus wieder verbreitet wird
wenn wir morgen wie update zu deutschen
arbeitnehmern erklären dort das
arbeitsheft die der verein führt und
haben sich die bedingungen der
produktion und der inder daraufhin hat
wolfgang post angewiesen dass es immer
noch so dass dort unter den klimatischen
bedingungen sich das virus besser
verbreiten kann als anderswo
ich muss jetzt leider dazwischen gehen
weil wir haben noch ein großes thema
über das wir noch mal kurz sprechen
wollten war ja card haben sie denn
aktien
herr bosbach ein glück drei vielen
anlegern sehr sehr viel geld über nacht
flöten gegangen ist eine nachricht die
einen börsenbeben auslöste
bezahldienstleister wirecard sind eben
mal knapp zwei milliarden euro
abhandengekommen war ja card hat am
montag bekanntgegeben oder zugegeben
oder zumindest nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
das bankguthaben bei philippinischen
banken mit insgesamt mehr als 1,9
milliarden euro
zitat mit überwiegender
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht bestehen
ja das entspricht etwa einem viertel der
bilanzsumme die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt inzwischen gegen den
zurückgetretenen chef markus braun der
vorwurf verdacht der bilanzfälschung und
manipulation des börsenkurses
und man stellt sich die frage war card
ist im online handel quasi
allgegenwärtig dem unternehmen hätte
eigentlich eine große zukunft bevor
gestanden
offenbar reichte das dem chef nicht ein
gutes geschäftsmodell zu haben und
soliden erfolg zu verzeichnen
es mussten bilanzen gefälscht werden
zahlen frisiert werden warum macht man
so was können sie das verstehen ganz
kurz später herr gabriel
weil das ja sein betrug ist die einzige
frage die sich stellt ist warum hat das
eigentlich der wirtschaftsprüfer erst
dieses jahr gemerkt und warum hat das
bundesamt für die kontrolle des
finanzwesens das eigentlich nicht vorher
schon untersucht obwohl es von der
financial times journalisten gab wie das
bereits längere zeit öffentlich gesagt
haben dass da vieles nicht stimmen das
ist doch wie bei anfragen jedes
nachgeben was sie haben eben auch genügt
offenbar haben alle kontrollen versagt
vom aufsichtsrat über die
rechnungsprüfer über die finanzaufsicht
welche lehren müssen daraus gezogen
werden bitte kurz ja die erste lehre ist
die und von ihnen angesprochene
strafrechtliche aufarbeitung ob es da
bilanzfälschungen marktmanipulationen
gegeben hat zum nachteil der gläubiger
zum nachteil der aktionäre
ob es scheingeschäfte gab und dann hat
sigmar gabriel völlig richtig darauf
hingewiesen vor einem jahr wurde schon
in der financial times über merkwürdige
geschäftsvorgänge berichtet was haben
die wirtschaftsprüfer in diesem zeitraum
12 monate unternommen
und was die bafin was wurde da geprüft
und was wurde unterlassen zu prüfen was
hätte geprüft werden müssen letzte frage
philipp am tor der cdu jungs da hat nun
doch eingesehen dass es aktuell
vielleicht nicht der richtige zeitpunkt
ist auch noch nach mehr zu streben will
jetzt nun doch nicht mehr chef des
landesverbands in mecklenburg vorpommern
werden wie groß war die erleichterung in
der cdu herr bosbach
ich glaube wenn er an der kandidatur
fest gehalten hätte und wenn er gewählt
worden wäre dass das eine belastung
gewesen wäre übrigens nicht nur für die
cdu in mecklenburg vorpommern sondern
für die bundes-cdu und den clip am tor
ist so jung er hat noch viele viele
jahre in der politik vor sich wenn er
jetzt aus seinem verhalten den
vorkommnissen die richtigen konsequenzen
zieht
herr gabriel haben sie etwa auch was aus
der cdu gehört eher von erleichterung
hat jemand sich ihnen anvertraute sowie
nötig dass die kollegen der union froh
darüber sein werden ist schon klar
so könnte das ganze jetzt und machen
indem man die einnahmen aus seinen
aktienoptionen und was er sonst so an
nebenverdiensten habe spendet zum
beispiel ein crooner auch war das wäre
dann mal tätige reue
vielen dank an sie beide das war der
klartext von heute und wir sehen uns
wieder am freitag bis dahin